جوله جديده من المعارك تلحف الافق في غزه
مع اطلاق الجيش الاسرائيلي حمله ضد حركه
الجهد الاسلامي بدايه الحمله كانت بعمليه
اسرائيليه اسفرت عن مقتل ثلاثه من ابرز
قاده سرايا القدس ذراع العسكريه لحركه
الجهاد الاسلاميه في قطاع غزه العمليه
تسببت ايضا في مقتل 13 شخصا اخرين من
عائلات وجيران القاده المستهدفين القاده
الثلاثه الذين سقطوا في هذا الهجوم هم
قائد المنطقه الشماليه في الجهاد خليل
البهتيني وامين سر المجلس العسكري لسرايا
القدس جهاد غنام اضافه لطارق عز الدين
المسؤول عن توجيه عدد من العمليات في
الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
العمليه الاسرائيليه كانت عنيفه وتم
خلالها استخدام القوه بشكل واضح فبحسب
الجيش الاسرائيلي فقد شاركت 40 طائره
اسرائيليه في هذه الغارات على غزه كما ان
التخطيط للعمليه بدا منذ شهر رمضان الماضي
حيث كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يرصد تحركات
قيادات الجهاد
هذا وقتلت اسرائيل فلسطينيين اثنين في
غاره استهدفت سياره جنوب قطاع غزه وقال
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف خليه كانت
تنمو اطلاق صاروخ مضاد للدروع
ولا شك ان التصعيد لا يتوقف عند هذا الحد
وهو ما اكده كلا الطرفين فحركه الجهاد
قالت ان ردها لي يتاخر على غارات اسرائيل
على غزه اما اسرائيل فتتاهب على جميع
الجبهات وهو ما اكده وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي الذي قال ان قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي ستبقى مستعده لكل السيناريوهات
في غزه بما في ذلك الحرب المطوله من جهته
هنا وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
رئيس الوزراء بنيام نتنياهو على العمليه
الاستباقيه في غزه مشيرا الى انها بدايه
موفقه لحمله مرتقبه
[موسيقى]
المعارضه الاسرائيليه بدورها اشادت بهذه
العمليه العسكريه وذلك على لسان زعيمها يا
ايرلابيد الاخير قال في تغريده له على
تويتر طبعا ان العمليه العسكريه للجيش
الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه اغلقت الحساب مع
قاده الجهات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات